well let's jump into the network of
switches and talk about combinatorial
algorithms if we could
let's step back with the very basics
what are combinatorial algorithms and
what are some major examples of problems
they aim to solve
a combinatorial algorithm is
is one which deals with a
a system of discrete objects that
can occupy various
states or take on various values from a
discrete set of values um
and need to be arranged or
or selected um in such a way as to
achieve some to minimize some cost
function
or to pro or to prove the existence of
some
combinatorial configuration so an
example would be
um coloring the vertices of a graph
what's a graph let's step back so what
uh
and it's fun to uh to ask
one of the greatest computer scientists
of all time the most basic questions in
the beginning of most books
but for people who might not know but in
general how you think about it what is
what is a graph
a graph that's that's simple it's a set
of points
certain pairs of which are joined by
lines
called edges and they
sort of represent the in different
applications represent the
interconnections between uh
discrete objects so they could be the
interactions interconnections between
switches
in a digital circuit or
interconnections indicating the
communication patterns of a human
community
and they could be directed or undirected
and then as you've mentioned before
might have costs right that can be
directed or undirected
you can be you can think of them as uh
if you're if
if you think if a graph were
representing a communication network
then the edge could be undirected
meaning that information could flow
along it in both directions or it could
be directed
with only one-way communication a road
system is another example of a graph
with weights on the edges and then
a lot of problems of
optimizing the efficiency of such
networks or
learning about the performance of such
networks
um uh are the
the object of combinatorial so it could
be
scheduling classes at a school where
the the
vertices the nodes of the network are
the individual
classes and the edges indicate the
constraints which say that certain
classes cannot take place at the same
time or
certain teachers are available only at
cert for certain classes
etc or
i talked earlier about the assignment
problem of matching the boys with the
girls
where you have their
graph with an edge from each boy to each
girl
with a weight indicating the cost or
in logical design of computers
you might want to find a
set of so-called gates switches
that perform logical functions which can
be interconnected to realize some
function
so you you might ask
how many gates do you need in order to
um
for for a circuit to
give a yes output if at least
a given number of its inputs are ones
and no if not a few are
are present
you